leslie n'a jamais accordé autant
d'attention au coût de ce qu'elle met
dans son panier d'épicerie
et surtout
une succession de m
elle et son mari sont à la retraite le
revenu au beau fixe
cette nouvelle coopérative alimentaire
dans la petite ville de sleaford offre à
ses membres de se servir sur les
étalages sans trop se préoccuper du prix
des aliments pour un peu plus de 7
dollars ils ont droit qu à 40 dollars de
nourriture qui provient de dons we see
no
des histoires auxquelles s'ajoutent
maintenant le choc violent d'une facture
d'énergie qui va tripler par rapport à
l'an passé
un foyer dépensera en moyenne
5400 $ par année dès le mois d'octobre
un fardeau qui est tous fra jusqu'aux
classes moyennes et aisées a prévenu le
ministre des finances du pays
sa frustration est partagée par de plus
en plus de travailleurs en fait c'est de
la colère qu'ils expriment chaque
semaine ou presque amène son lot de
mécontents sur les piquets de grève
éboueur cheminots employés du métro de
londres ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à demander un meilleur
traitement en arrêtant le travail
les dockers du port de felixstowe
n'étaient pas allés en grève depuis 30
ans des bodin's encore la preuve
même les avocats s'y mettent il ne
défendrons puis d'accuser jusqu'à ce que
la demande soit entendu di censo wenger
a manqué par h2s dit christine nice et
marseille
on dit ça ne suffit d'une série les
hommes précédente du web tous ces
débrayages ont un point commun le recul
du pouvoir d'achat
en juillet l'inflation a atteint 10,1
course en grande bretagne et elle
pourrait dépasser les 13% en octobre
voire 10 8% en janvier selon des
prédictions pessimistes
c'est le niveau le plus élevé d'un pays
du g7 de ce week end
depuis sa démission en juillet boris
johnson assure un service à minima
évitant les grandes décisions
broker richissime il sent moins de 200
mille membres il représente environ 0,3
pour cent de la population britannique
ce sont surtout des hommes blancs et
plus âgés à l'aise financièrement
en choisissant leur nouveau chef les
conservateurs choisissent aussi le
prochain premier ministre pour
l'ensemble des 67 millions de
britanniques
pensent que
c'est entre lyss cross ministre des
affaires étrangères positionné très à
droite i wish i sounac ancien ministre
des finances démissionnaire du cabinet
de boris johnson que les conservateurs
doivent trancher
à moins d'une grosse surprise liste ross
devrait l'emporter facilement pour
devenir la troisième femme à gouverner
la grande bretagne celle qui a d'abord
fait campagne contre les briques site
pour ensuite en devenir une ardente
défenseure apporter une promesse
constante qui rejoint le coeur des
électeurs conservateurs des baisses
d'impôts et pas de charité les taxes aux
fans de miley
[Musique]
travailler fort faire des sacrifices
edit et suzanne filming ne sont pas
contre seulement le jeune couple de
boston n'a plus rien à donner
je
prends ma famille tous les deux sont
préposés aux bénéficiaires en santé
pendant la cause ils ont été célébrés
comme des héros d'un système public au
bord du gouffre après des années
d'austérité budgétaire aujourd'hui ils
n'attendent plus grand-chose d'un
gouvernement qui les a déçus eric est
ringard
[Musique]
qui comme heineken l'expression
consacrée est né dans les bureaux de la
propagande pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale elle devait rassurer les
anglais le ça va bien aller d'une autre
époque kenyon continuer ils n'ont guère
d'autre choix quant aux rester calme le
ou la prochaine première ministre de la
grande bretagne devra composer avec un
peuple qui n'a plus du tout les moyens
de son flegme légendaire